hello everyone sorry about no videos for
the past few days I was really feeling
terrible you know had fever the costs
being disgusting and all and I'm not
even sure if I'll be able to complete
this one but I will give it a go it's a
game from around 10 of the 2019 Tata
Steel chess festival again between
Magnus Carlsen and Vishwanathan Anand
two old rivals who battled it out two
times for the World Chess Championship
title once in their 2013 match and in
2014 rematch and it's always an
interesting battle between the two of
them now I do hope you'll enjoy this
game is it's really interesting and I
really would like to thank everyone who
sent me emails and nice comments about
am i all right and everything and I
think well thank you for worrying but
getting back to this game without
further ado as I I'm really not sure if
I'll be able to finish the video my my
throat is still killing me calls and
opens with E 4 we have e5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 the rule
opus is on the board a six amorphous
defense we have Bishop play for Knight
to f6 Knight to c3 Bishop to c5 now and
here Bishop captures this delayed
capture on c6 d captures and now d3 and
here this position has occurred several
times in high tier at top-tier
tournaments for example there was a game
in 2007 between Richard Robert ending
leerin that ended very quickly after
castles Queen e2 rocky 8 h3 Knight d7
and then just a few maneuvers Knight
d-19 f8 and 93 and here they agreed to a
draw so such games are also possible but
this is not one such game here are not
place Queen to d6 it's a new move in
this position never happened before
which is a rare that on the move 7 in
the rule opus you have a completely new
game but very interesting of course now
we have h3 by column preventing the
development of the Bishop to g4 Bishop
to e6 Bishop to e3 constant develops
counters the Bishop on c5 and here
Knight to d7 open
up the possibility for capturing with
the night if constant decides to do so
but also in some ideas some light for
example castles f5 is an idea and so on
cousin does capture we have the best of
captures tonight captures and now Queen
to d2 across and leaves the possibility
for both King side and queenside
castling night back to the seven by
Anand not allowing before to come with
an attack on the night but also making
room for black to be able to push c5 we
have d 4e captures Knight captures and
now c5 kicking back the night and now a
trade of Queens will become possible
Knight captures and here on the could
capture with the Queen but he does
capture with the pawn so obviously he
has something prepared
we have queenside castle by Carlsen and
now Queen captures on b2 and now as
cousins playing this game for the first
time since that Queen to d6 appears to
be a novelty capturing what the rope
does seem to be the appropriate thing to
do here and then for example Robo d8
let's say rock age the d1 white can
double up but it's hard to say if black
can make you if white can make use of
this you can go King b7 connect rooks
and after f4 let's say you decide to
trade off everything you're left with
the same game where white is just what
is better of course to the Black has
three point islands and the CC pawn
white has two point islands and no no
pawn irregularities but obviously if
Anand was prepared for this it doesn't
seem like white will be able to go for
anything
as on this prepared so that it could be
one of the reasons why Carson here
decides to go for King captures and e2
and I mean could be could be a nice idea
for example if the King can come to e3
you can push before the team can be a
valuable piece so on and goes the e5 he
well first if knocking each reason you
can always kick it away with Knight to
c4 but also makes room for the rook to
come to d8 calls and pushes it back we
have f4 nice the c-4 would check King
back to c1 and now we have King to e7
Ahnold connect rooks rooks we have b3
the night away and now not III if you go
here yes you do attack the rock in the
pond but after a rogue defense pawn your
light is trapped let's say Rock 88 rocky
do and the night has nowhere to go
so after be three we have Knight to d6
now comes in five ninety five and not
cross and improves the position of his
night while attacking the undefended c5
pawn so on and defends it and now we
have g4 and here Anand goes nice to h4
so it's hard to say if if that rope
capture some t2 was better than
constants keen captures on d2 but at
least now instead of that position that
we've shown it's a much more complicated
position for the moment Anand has a
knight on the rim and you know there are
quite a few possibilities
rook h2 f1 by constant in Luke 8 to d8
offering the rook trade constant except
rook captures rook captures and now f5
and okay we have a captures on f5 d
captures and now rook to f8 defending
the pawn twice and you can't defend the
pawn if you try something like this then
you get g6 and the black will just be
better here after f6 check you have to
attack it and now if you defend it then
comes nine three attacks the rook and
the pawn wherever you move the rook
black will snatch the pawn and just be a
proponent much better most likely
winning
so after Luke f8 across some place f6
check we have pawn captures pawn
captures with check King to f7 and not
rook to f4 a nice rock lifts taking
advantage of this night being stranded
on the rim Knights the g6 and now Knight
to g5 with check you have to go to you
have to go to e8 team to e8 and now
comes rock back to f1 out of harm's way
and now we have h6 kicking the knight
back nice to e6 attacking the rook and
the pawn and here we have Luke to f7
defending and rook to d1
rook to e1 seems like a nice idea
threatening all sorts of discoveries but
after King d7 your rook is just stuck
guarding the night and then Roe captors
on f6 is coming so
after this rook to f7 move we have rook
to d1 now black has to be very careful
if Anand is not careful and goes for
something like 95 then even route to d8
the checkmate becomes a possibility as
the ponies controlling these seven
square so you do have to decide what you
want to do do you want to play rook d7
offer a trade of rooks
Anand doesn't go for this rather he
decides to go for rook captures on f6 he
decides to give up the two Queen side
pawns we have light captures which check
came to f8 and now Knight captures on
age seven and a six and Allen goes for
the King side pawn Knight to h4 sorry
about that here it would be a bit too
soon to go look to H 1 as the rook on h1
will be very passive now just guarding
the pawn on h3 rather we have h4
Michaelson and only now after Knight to
g6 and now rook to h1 because now h5 can
come with an attack on the knight on g6
for example if we're okay for attacking
the pawn and pawn can come here and then
after only after the knight moves rook
to d1 and our district can come whoops
and attack on the other pawns so after
Luke - h1 we have grouped to f7 by Anand
and now comes h5 Knight to f4 and now a
4 here the pawns are very nicely
connected very safe and Carson wants to
introduce now his King into the game
either by let's say here here and then
going c3 let's well not there of course
but let's say this would be a nice nice
path and the King can also pressure the
Queen cyclones
King to e7 by Arnold we have nice to c7
and now King to f6 attacking the knight
and night to b5
rook the f1 doesn't really do anything
the black will be very happy with this
trade for example captures captures King
g5 attacking the rook and the pawn
so after this scheme to have sex with
Knights to be 5 and now King to g5
pressuring this pawn twice nice the d6
attacking the rook rook 3 7 and now King
to be two across and finally starts
bringing his King into the game and here
you could capture the pawn but it would
give Qasim
plenty more time to go after the
queenside pawns so here first rook to e6
attacking the knight now knight of seven
check King to f5 and now rook to d1
threatening some very nice ideas for
example if Arnold now captures the pawn
which is of course possible but if
Knight captures then you get this a5
move a very interesting idea as now
after pawn captures you have this these
two week pawns on the Queen side rogue
d5 check you can block with the Rope
denied controls this so you have to
let's say attack the knight King g6 but
now you get a 95 check King moves 97
check King e7 and now you can capture
like this roll capture screen captures
and row captures here and now you cannot
start pushing this pawn the rook
controls it you are threatening to
capture this pawn the King will also
come help out it will perhaps this is
some sort of a theoretical draw for
black but it's hard it's hard to decide
to give white all this much if you have
a nice position like this
so instead Allen was King to g4 we have
King to c3 cross and starts bring his
King into the game and now he captures
with the King rather keen captures and
now rook to h1 check King moves and now
Knight captures on h6 so it was very
important to eliminate blacks passed
pawn on the on the Queen King side rook
to e4 cutting off the King from
advancing anywhere across the
fourth-ranked and now comes King back to
be do rook to e2 with some ideas of
pinning the spawn but also Knight the d3
check will be an idea nice the g4 cousin
wants to activate this night as soon as
possible Knights to d3 check we have
King to c3 and now comes Knight to be
four and this Knight is now excellently
placed here as you can see there's a lot
of pressure against the c2 pawn so
here's how Carlsen deals with it
rook to h2 that's the only way to deal
with it offering a trader Brooks and
here Anand can decide whether he wants
to keep rooks on the board for example
let's
rook to e4 attacks the knight avoids the
trade and leaves this night here to be a
nuisance for Carson to always have to
deal with but he decides to trade rocks
he plays rook captures Knight captures
unlocking to f5 saying that okay you
have upon advantage but your advantage
of upon his on the same side as my pawns
I will just bring my king and there's no
way for you to win this
Carson goes the knight to f3 we have
King to e4 and now comes night Stewie
one King to d5 and not night the d3 and
now of course if Arnold would trade
nights then this upon three points
against two points would be a winning
position for white so of course Anand
decides not to trade Knight to c6 and
now comes Knight to f4 check Carson has
the figure out a way how to improve his
position King to d6
we have King to c4 and now comes Knight
to a7 you don't want to allow this King
ever to go to be 5 so night from a7
controls it so again you have to figure
out how to make progress here across and
try son 95 we have king c6 Knight e7
check King d6 95 check King c6 and now
King to d3 just the asking questions we
have King to c7 by Anand kinky for we
have lied back to c6 Knight the e3 and
now King to d6 Knight to c4 check
attacking both the king and the b6 pawn
king to c7 defending and now c3 slowly
but surely improving the position of the
King tonight the point is very nice on
c3 taking away the b4 and the d4 square
from black's knight we have 97 and now
King to 85
so some progress has been made is it
enough it's hard to say it's very hard
to win to win any any advantages such as
this 196 check we have King to f5 night
the e7 check King to e6 and now tonight
back to g6 and here you can see that the
knight has now somewhat bit somewhat
been cut off from the play by a call
since King and here cousin plays a 5
well now what do you do here well you
obviously have a couple of questions you
could push push the pawn you would
capture on a5 so feel free to pause the
video here and you don't really try to
soak in the position and decide what you
would play here so I will not be
congratulating everyone this time as
it's a bit of a different position but
we will come back to this position at
some point here on undecided to push b5
he attacked call since night and here we
have Knight e3 and what has happened
here so from that position a few moves
ago now we have a position where Carlson
has a past
a pawn which is well which is always
very nice to have it's a past it's an
outside passed pawn and it's well soon
soon to be a connected pass pawn and
protected Knight to f4 check we have
King to e5 and now comes Knight to e2
attacking the c3 pawn and Crossing uses
the Knights to defend it of course 95
check we have King to c6 and now comes
before so the pawns are now connected
and here you have again a choice do you
want to capture or do you want to push
the pawn let's let's explore a few
options if you capture the pawn then you
get C captures unbel and now how do you
play this it would be very bad for black
if white would push a 6 then the knight
would control d6 the pond would control
b7 and it will be how well very
difficult to stop the pawn so let's say
night C 197 check King b7 and now white
will just advance his King and at some
point white will be able to capture this
pawn as well for example King to a6 now
comes nice the c6 Knight to b3 check
King d5 nice to d2 but now comes Knight
d4 and after Knight to c4 you would get
nice to be three we have nice to a3
but now comes King to c6 and now you
have this problem where after black
plays Knight to c4 you will have nice
the c5 check King will have
to move and then kink after some b5 I
have a two-point advantage this will be
completely winning
so after this b4 obviously cannot
capture can push c4 c4 is a bit of a
different story but also quite similar
for example King e6 King b7 King desex
for example king a6 you want to keep
defending everything but king c6 and yes
now you do pressure the c3 pawn but to
white can outmaneuver black here for
example black now has to make a move
either black will move the King and you
will capture here or you will have to
leave your pressure of the c3 pawn and
now after we play nice the c1 white
always has 97 check you have to move the
King and now comes King capture some b5
and you lose even more material you will
have three connected pass bonds against
the King and night
so after this b4 move it seems that
Anand can capture or push c4 so here on
and decides Knight captures on c3 and
okay we have Knight captures on c3 see
capture some before and here I really
want you to pause the video and decide
what to play here I will give a couple
of seconds as usual also it will be a
nice opportunity to for me to grab some
water for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations there is only one
move here that is good for white and
that is Knight to e2 which is what cross
and played so let's just see what
happens if you can play something like
Knight to d5 we've tried to d5 then like
just plays b3 and then after you play
nice the before check the black King
will move you will go nice to the d3 and
then King to a6 will eliminate your
passed pawn and it is all over but here
the problem with nice to e2 which is
what cousin played and it was in this
position that Vishwanathan unreasoned
the game
the problem is next now if you try the
same idea let's say King goes here to go
to a six now Knight the c1 is the
problem because you also guard b3 from
the pawn but also after King to a6 you
get tonight b3 and the pawn is protected
after King b7 you will just advance your
King as usual by taking
seven king c6 King a six King to c5 now
the King finally has to move King b7 and
now he starts snatching up pawns and now
you can push up on to victory as there's
no way for black to stop this swim after
this nice to eat you move like we said
which is the only move that's going to
congratulations if you found it
charlatan Anand resigned at the game but
I did mention that we will return to
that moment where Island had to make a
choice just just a second after this
nice to g6 that on a plate cousin played
85 and here aren't pushed b5 but there
was a one I don't know for those of you
who really did pause the video and
thought about this position it seems the
correct way was be captures on a5 and
now there are different ways to proceed
this for example this one isn't going
anywhere so it's better for white to go
immediately after this pawn but now you
get knife to it for check King captures
on c5 and now Knight to e2 first
attacking the c3 pawn but now after
night to a3 you get not tonight captures
on c3 Knight captures on c3 is bad
because all night to b5 check here black
would have to trade white will grab this
and then it's a beep on this position of
the White King is excellent it would be
a winning game for white but instead
after night to a3 you have night the c1
and now there doesn't seem to be a way
for white to the windows for example
nice to be 5 check King b7 you could go
Knight to d4 now defend your b3 pawn but
now King to a 6 you're defending your
pawn here and after King to d6 you will
get a 4 you will even temporarily give
up another pawn after be captures here
now you will go King to a5 to go after
this point and then you will at some
point sacrifice the knife for the other
point and it's a draw for example c4 you
could go Knight to d3 and now after c5
you'll simply capture that King captures
and after King afters here it's a draw
by insufficient material
so really a tough a tough position this
has already moved 70 the the games have
been going on for I don't know six hours
and you have you've been playing an
excellent game for the entire game
you've you've been having an excellent
tournament and then it basically all
comes down to this choice whether to
play B captures on a5 or to push b5 but
yeah that's most likely one of the
reasons Carson is a world champion
because he's able to play after that as
Anand Anand came with a prepared line
and already in that moment where we
mentioned after bunch of characters here
that Queen captures whether Qasim would
have played rook captures or King
captures already here going into this
long long long long end game and then
just like the title suggests starts
asking questions all the time every move
for as long as possible and then in the
end it's some it's somehow pays off it
works the you know they do already have
the name for it every time they use it
it's the Magnus effect so this time this
time wish you got the the worst part of
it but yeah 92 the end of the game and I
did prepare the the standings after
round 10 so here they are so it's a bit
poorly stretched but yeah okay it
doesn't matter
as you can see after 10 rounds Carson is
leading well he's so leader with 7 out
of 10 with with a top rating performance
of 20 892 almost 2900 followed by
onigiri with six and a half out of ten
then nepo and bing leerin and we found
an island with six then tomorrow java in
the gujarati with five out of ten then
one will first serve similar Shanklin
and richard report and the initiation of
Duda would four and a half Jordan van
forest with four mama Dara with four and
then one kramnik with two out of two and
a half out of ten which is which is a
25% performance that is
not something anyone would expect from
Vladimir Kramnik former raw champion but
it says there saying I mean it's it's as
if someone abducted him and placed an
impostor here in Tata still to play
instead of one mere Kramnik but as I
already mentioned I believe in my
previous video everyone has a bad
tournament at some point I don't believe
Kramnik had one in quite some time
if you remember in 2017 when Carlson
played in his homeland
the OtterBox Norway championship he
finished last not last a carjacking was
last he was second to last with I
believe something like four out of nine
yeah I believe Kirk in three and a half
out of nine Carlsen four out of nine so
everyone has a bad tournament for now on
them but yes you can see even with this
loss
Anand still with six points in fifth
place
well shared third actually so as there
are three more rounds to go in this
tournament
anyone can still you know clinch first
place it's not a problem you know anyone
who wins the next three games definitely
has an opportunity to win so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I will
see how I'll be feeling tomorrow hope I
will be able to make more videos I would
like to thank our own Vince Hassan risk
20 more guitar
Jory Hanson and John Gear law office for
a contribution to my channel thank a lot
- really appreciate it as usual you can
check - on my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and hopefully I will continue
the cup of lanka saga soon enough
so once again thank you all for the best
wishes and I will see you soon